Brian mitchell,
who's first name is spelled like mine,
m a r I a,
but it's pronounced Mariah and not
Maria,
is the first recognized female
astronomer in America and was the first
woman elected unanimously to the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences in
1831 when she was still a teenager
obsessed with stargazing.
She heard that the king of Denmark had
offered a gold metal valued at 20 ducats
cats,
which was a lot of money at the time to
the first person to discover a
telescopic comic.
It took her 16 years to master the
science and the craft of observation,
but she did become the first person and
see 18,
47.
T one was known for a hundred years as
ms dot Mitchell's comments.
Later when she was hired to teach
astronomy at Vassar,
the newly established Vassar College,
she was the first woman on the faculty
and according to the official handbook
of college rules,
female students were not allowed to go
outside after dark.
This was a problem for the study of
astronomy.
I'm Mitchell fought tirelessly to
overturn not just this,
but many other roles based on antiquated
gender norms that held back women in
science.
Later,
she was hired as the first woman to
perform a nondomestic specialized skill
for the US federal government.
She was paid $300 a year for her job as
a computer,
a Venus for the United States Nautical
Almanac.
It was a very,
very mathematically rigorous job that
require her to perform very complex
calculations that would predict the
position of Venus in the sky for years
to come.
And in the days before gps and
satellites.
This is how sailors all over the world
navigated the oceans.
By the time she was 40,
Mitchell had reached celebrity status as
one of the most famous women in the
world,
which is a remarkable feat for a
scientist even today.
We don't have many celebrity scientists,
uh,
but she was most beloved for her
extraordinary generosity of spirit that
went along with her genius.
She didn't much care for the accolades
and the recognition and the celebrity,
but she went out of her way to mentor
and help cultivate the talents of women
in science,
uh,
which required that she overcame her
painful shyness in order to be a public
speaker and a public figure and a role
model and an educator,
which he continued to be.
She continue to teach right up until her
death.
Hm.